each criminal bracket within mafia 3 is
made up of various different differing
objectives all of the open-world
activities in the game and quests and
missions are all linked to the main
narrative of this criminal racket the
player picks and chooses which ones they
want to complete in order to do enough
damage to that racket lure that hideout
boss out to defend his turf so to speak
in reference to our sort of construction
yard racket Lincoln can shakedown
foremen who are overseeing the
construction project in order to get
more information out of them of how this
racket is working that in turn will
unlock other missions at Lincoln
comparte con we've put a lot of work
into actually modeling the way the Mafia
operates and how it kind of seeps into
the foundations of a city they had
bosses for running different parts of
the city and they all have specialties
they have like these big businesses that
they're using to launder money when
whatever illicit things that they need
to do each of the rackets are protected
by these enforcer characters throughout
the world so these guys are sort of the
muscle that oversee the operation for
sale Marko knows guys once you take out
these guys you're gonna do extra damage
for the operation because it's gonna run
much less smoothly so because every
player story is unique in our games we
don't dictate that you take these guys
out but they're big targets and you
probably want to go after them the
enforces that Lincoln is not taken down
at that point will actually fall back
into the hideout in turn making that
hideout
much much harder to to sort of take on
the players incentive ice to go around
the open-world and actually take on
these guys take on these guys in their
own turf destroy them where they are
rather than facing them at the end where
they could increase the scope of the
hideout and the challenge of the hideout
exponentially